as Syrian and Russian forces attempted
to retake land lost to rebels on
Thursday Turkish forces supporting the
rebels came under fire their bloodiest
day in the conflict so far as a result
of the airstrikes 33 soldiers have been
martyred helicopters and ambulances were
seen streaming across the border earlier
in the day to evacuate the wounded
returning tejate as crowds gathered
outside the hospital turkey says it's
responding by attacking every known
Syrian government target using missiles
and also at the same time the artillery
forces from the border are strongly
hitting the air defense systems and many
ammunition depots of the regime forces
the situation which the opposition was
being back to Turkish ant forces will
change everything because from now on
they will see not only the opposition on
the ground but also the manual and the
firepower of the Turkish armed forces
including the air force it lifted a
Danish Melodi the developments in Eid
Lib have turned back in our favor hours
earlier President Recep Tayyip Erdogan
had hailed the battlefield successes
Turkey has thousands of troops in it Lib
supporting rebel forces at war with
Syrian troops backed by Russia turkish
airstrikes have been pounding Syrian
government positions for days a
de-escalation zone agreement between
Turkey and Russia signed in 2018 was
intended to prevent such fighting and
protect 4 million civilians living there
far from de-escalation there's an
unfolding calamity for civilians enid
Lib as turkey and its rebels battle
Syria and Russia the situation is
worsening by the day
the escalation of fighting in the
northwest since December has pushed over
900,000 people including over half a
million children away from their homes
and into danger whatever happens with
said akkad
won't end there or anytime soon turkey
says it will deepen its involvement in
Syria against the government it's now
labeled the enemy under Chapelle al
Jazeera I mean get the very latest now
by talking to our correspondent sinem
Koziol ooh she is in Istanbul and sinem
it seems very much as so the activities
of the last 24 hours in Italy province
and bringing the two sides ever closer
to direct confrontation to war exactly
Martin actually a couple of days ago
turkish president aragon while speaking
he said we are at war but no one guessed
that it would be something like that for
and since this latest escalation started
in in December 2019 in in the front
lines inside Italy it's always like this
they they almost come face-to-face but
yesterday was something different
because this is the first time that so
many soldiers are hit at once and killed
at once that's why the officials have
reacted harshly yesterday and we heard
from the presidential representatives
that Turkey is retaliating and they have
retaliated but of course this is a
critical process because Turkey has many
troops inside Italy first the troops
went there based on the Sochi agreement
and Astana agreement that it would be a
de-escalation zone and Turks and
Russians would would establish military
observation posts to observe the
possible violations of the de-escalation
but after the latest tension turkey
deployed and more reinforcements more
troops but I have to tell that the
airspace is closed by the Russians and
the Syrian regime so whatever success
the Turkish forces and the rebels gain
on the ground there is always this
possibility like it happened yesterday
they can hit either the regime and
Russians can hit from and there is no
way out for them ok sinem i just want to
ask you if you could also as briefly as
possible please what is the nature of
the operation of the Turkish operation
now against
what it's calling all known Syrian
targets do we have any detail as to how
this operations unfolding well so far as
I said it was just an observation
mission for the Turks but beginning from
the end of January it has turned out
like a combat mission because there are
also combat soldiers on the ground and
the rebels are on the ground and after
yesterday's incident I've been hearing
that the command level was given orders
to hit any foreign item or element in
the airspace and Turks are ready to hit
Syria from land and air from the bases
inside Turkey which our main lady is in
the southeastern city Dr Bakr base and a
from angelic face today we will be
learning more about the military mission
how they're gonna conduct how they're
gonna respond but it turns out Turkey
will retaliate at any means from now on
because the military is also very angry
and the motivation of the soldiers over
there is very down Martin all right
thank you psyllium cause here lose live
in Istanbul